c'est le plus connu des candidats à la
direction du parti québécois
lorsqu'on s'appelle pierre karl péladeau
un petit rassemblement à la cabane à
sucre se transforme rapidement en grand
bain de foule
sa fortune et son parcours impressionne
tous veulent lui serrer la main surtout
se faire photographier avec lui
la seule qui parviennent à me faire de
l'ombre
et nul autre que sa conjointe julie
snyder
bon on va dévoiler une nouvelle pole
cocotte le japon c'est parti
depuis leur naissance remis six ans et
thomas 9 ans ont toujours eu l'habitude
de six week-ends de passer à s'amuser au
chalet même lorsque leur père dirigeait
quebecor et depuis quelques mois les
fins de semaine en famille sont plus
rares la ville est exigeante parce que
bon et à juste titre vous savez des
militants veulent vous voir veulent vous
rencontrer tous les enfants vivent des
difficultés dans le travail de leurs
parents
on s'est dit on culpabilise pas là
dessus nos enfants et vivre des choses
extraordinaires et vivre des choses
moins facile du métier
pour pierre karl péladeau dirigé
quebecor était devenue confortable trop
confortable leur était arrivé de laisser
éclore une autre ambition
j'ai toujours pensé que le québec de 21
pays bon jeu très bon jour il avoue y
avoir longuement réfléchi avoir planifié
son coup
eq tessa s'improvise pas surtout
évidemment lorsque vous avez des
responsabilités comme étaient les
miennes intérieurement
moi je me disais ça va y passer noté
c'est comme quelque chose que tu
souhaites faire un jour mais ça va te
passer le message y croyait paul il m'a
dit je veux vivre selon mes convictions
je peux vivre jeu pour vivre pour mon
confort legic rue j'ai tout dit croire
mais d'hommes d'affaires un homme
politique
la marche et les attentes et devis puis
qu'une qu'on va continuer une phobie
soccer son style hilton choque parfois
ses rapports avec les journalistes sont
souvent tendues c'est pas comme ça que
ça fonctionne actuellement ce plateau
sur le plat que vous n'aimez société
comme ça que ça fonctionne bien parce
qu'une oreille à des questions aux
idiots de questions cribles et n'est pas
hypocrite n'est pas capable de faire
semble et ça peut-être que ça lui ennuis
mais en même temps c'est probablement sa
plus grande force si certaines personnes
vont dire que je m'exprime pas
nécessairement de la façon de la plus
adéquate
mes idées peuvent peut-être d'étonner à
certains égards s'cusez moi excusez moi
parce que je dois absolument changer
pour devenir en position d'arrière où tu
es de rester ce que je suis
honnêtement je pense que je vais rester
ce que je suis votre écrit par pauline
marois alors que le pq avait le vent
dans les voiles
pkp ne pensait pas occuper cité de
l'avant-scène faire du québec un pays
déclarations controversées discours
parfois décousus l'aspirant chef tribut
avec la démographie avec d'immigration à
chaque côté démunis sans expérience
parlementaire s'était tu es un festival
permanent de la découverte
plus à l'aise dans une usine qu'à
l'assemblée nationale pierre karl
péladeau mis sur le contact direct avec
les électeurs
au coeur de son message deux priorités
la croissance économique et
l'indépendance
lors de ses visites il est bien
accueillie les entrepreneurs le voit
déjà premier ministre en rien ses
premiers mineurs
vous n'allez pas dans vos premiers 100
jours une étape à la voir mais avoir
dirigé une entreprise peut aussi être
passif
certains ses adversaires appel à micro
fermé la façon brutale dont il a géré
les conflits de travail au journal de
québec et au journal de montréal pierre
karl péladeau lui même semble avoir pris
du recul sur ses années à la tête de
quebecor c'est comme au baseball bud et
power les romains puis frappé un coup de
circuit à chaque fois ils m'ont rien dit
très bons gestes lieu déjà ce qu'ils ont
certainement été peut-être pas à la
hauteur de nos expectative mais c'est
normal
l'économie donc mais d'abord
l'indépendance et des paradors épaules
chiffre d'affaires nous avons eu des
inquiétudes des craintes d'en parler de
l'indépendance depuis les dernières
années peut-être comme eu un traumatisme
après 95 alors c'est certain que si nous
voulons faire l'indépendance nous devons
en parler parler d'indépendance
le pari est risqué pkp doit pourtant
réussir
lui qui a tout mis de côté poursuivre
son rêve de faire du québec le pays
c'est ce que je m'engage à faire si je
le privilège d'être choisie ne cherche
pas si les bois